or pour quelles raisons l'arabie
saoudite alliée des etats-unis est
quasiment intouchable éléments de
réponse avec pierre conesa il est ancien
haut fonctionnaire spécialiste des
questions stratégiques et
internationales
c'est au fur à mesure qu'ils voulaient
que l'arabie saoudite va s'afficher
comme une espèce de d'acteur
international absolument essentiel sur
le plan du moyen-orient et donc à partir
dont notamment abonnement il yal'art 79
la révolution iranienne on sait que les
alliés sont peu nombreux mais pour
l'essentiel ce sont des socialistes à
ras bord les socialistes arabes sont
plus proche de moscou que de washington
donc les alliés sont relativement peu de
washington sont relativement rares et
l'arabie saoudite en est un ils ont qu'à
partir de ce moment là effectivement
vous avez un système d'alliances qui
fait qu'on va passer surtout ce que
musclée l'arabie saoudite c'est à dire
un des pays de théocratie les plus
obscurs de la planète l'oppression des
fables les condamnations humaines les
pendaisons et cédera donc vous voulez on
a un jeu au passif à l'égard de l'arabie
saoudite